there is a sociological phenomena called
Godwin's law which says that when an
online discussion goes on long enough
someone is guaranteed to bring up
Adolphe Hitler and it has never been
more true than the comments of our
videos that's right the time has come
for us to finally talk about the biggest
Nazi of them all out of Hitler now most
of us have learned about World War two
in the Holocaust in history class but
very few people know about Adolf
Hitler's personal life his early years
in his rise to power show us how one man
used fear and anger of the German people
to manipulate other human beings he
transforms a nation into a force of hate
and destruction that was responsible for
the deaths of millions of people and
today on by graphics we bring you the
infamous life of a dog Hitler
today's story begins even before
Hitler's birth his father al Weiss was
an illegitimate child of a 42 year old
peasant named Maria and a schickel
Gruber she had never been married and
supported herself by working as a
housekeeper for wealthy Jewish families
in Austria Maria left the name of
Alice's father blank on his baptism
certificate so no one has any way of
knowing who Hitler's biological
grandfather actually is a few years
later Maria married a man named Johann
Georg Hiedler so both she and alloys
both took on his last name but when the
priest wrote their marriage certificate
he spelled their last name Hitler
instead this name means the one who
lives in a hut it's not exactly the most
flattering last name but for some reason
they decided to keep it Maria died at
the age of 51 when Alice was just 10
years old he went on to live in his
stepfathers family farm where he worked
hard on his keep as a teenager he
apprenticed under a cobbler and learns
the art of leather making he was
ambitious so he got a job with the
Austrian Ministry of Finance and this
put him firmly in the middle-class
alloys Hitler got married and divorced
twice before marrying his third wife
Clara Rapunzel they had two children who
died in infancy before finally giving
birth to a healthy son on April the 20th
1889 they named him Adolphus Hitler
they weren't long to have another son
Edmund in 1894 Adolphe Hitler was
rebellious and lazy for a murrain young
age and he did not get good grades
his father was an angry man and he would
beat at all frequently when he
misbehaved his mother in contrast was
very protective and would show him
unconditional love no matter how badly
he behaved at 8 years old he again
singing in his church choir and his
mother formed over him telling him that
he was the most talented boy in the
church she believes in him so much that
she paid for him to have private voice
lessons he told his parents that he
wanted to be a Catholic priest and he
was already preaching to other children
I've until this point there was a small
never of hope that maybe Hitler could
have turned out to be a normal person
but in the year 1900 his younger brother
Edmund he died of the measles the
graveyard where Edmund was married just
so happened to be across the street from
their house so he was never able to
properly mourn and move on with his life
out of Hitler was only 11 years old at
that time and he became incredibly
depressed the boy spent a lot of time
hanging out in the graveyard lying next
to his brother's grave late into the
night he was talk out loud to his dead
brother
stare at the Stars according to Hitler
he was afraid of his father and he only
loved his mother alloys could probably
see that this son desperately need a
disciplined structure in his life but
Clara was always there to swoop in and
baby him unfortunately alloys did not
live long enough to make sure that
Adolph learned to take responsibility
for himself alloys Hitler died in 1903
when Adolf was 14 years old
Clara didn't protest when Adolf decided
to drop out of high school at the age of
16 instead of pushing him to actually do
something with his life his mother
allowed him to become a NEET which is
someone who is not participating in
education employment or training as we
mentioned earlier the family was
middle-class they certainly weren't
wealthy and now that his father had
passed away his mother was on a strict
budget but young Adolf he'd like to walk
around town wearing fancy clothes and
carrying a cane pretending to be an
independently wealthy man he never
worked a day in his life and his mother
had built up his ego so much that he
truly believed that he deserved to get
everything simply handed to him just
because he existed one of the people in
town asked what young Adolf Hitler plans
to do with his life he declared that he
would be the greatest artist in the
world
Hitler applied to be in the Academy of
Fine Arts in Vienna Austria but he was
rejected he wrote I was so convinced
that I would be successful that when I
received my rejection it struck me as a
bolt from the blue the paintings that
have been attributed to Hitler are
nothing special even after years of
practice it's clear that he had certain
delusions of grandeur Clara Hitler died
in 1907 from breast cancer when Adolf
was 18 years old he was crushed because
he loved his mother more than anyone in
the world now that both of his parents
were dead you'd think that he maybe you
know get a job but no he still had this
baffling sense of entitlement and he
believed that he shouldn't have to work
because he still believed he could be
Europe's greatest artist Hitler moved to
Vienna and he lived like a king off the
inheritance that his parents had left
behind alloys Hitler he worked his
entire life to save up that money for
retirement and spent all of it in a
single year after this he was so broke
that he ended up having to live in
homeless shelters desperate for income
Hitler wrote to family and friends
asking them to support his life as an
artist considering that the majority of
his relatives were in the working-class
the replies were not very surprising
they told him to get a
job however he did convince at least one
art to start sending him money for his
basic needs after years of practicing on
a daily basis he finally started making
a small income by selling watercolor
paintings to local businesses and
tourists but he would never be able to
support himself fully from his art in
1913 Hitler moved to Munich Germany and
continued to paint and sell his
watercolors when World War one began
there was a new sense of enthusiasm in
German pride his career as a painter it
clearly wasn't going anywhere so he
joined the German army once he was in
the military he thrived after having
some discipline and structure put into
his life he still had a lot of
confidence in himself no matter what he
did and this helped him rise through the
ranks until he became a corporal he
believed that Germany should have won
the war and he blamed Jewish propaganda
as the reason why they didn't win when
the war was over in 1918 kaiser wilhelm
ii was forced to step down from his
throne Germany created a new government
called the vimar republic and they
signed the Treaty of Versailles in 1919
in article 231 of the treaty it states
the Allied and associated governments
affirm and Germany accepts the
responsibility for causing all of the
loss and damage as a consequence of the
war imposed upon them by the aggression
of Germany and her allies they were
forced to pay money to all of the
countries for all of the damage that
they had caused as well as give up 13%
of their land following the war the
Vimal Republic had struggled to deal
with the crippling debt from the Treaty
of a sign this new government it tried
to create jobs through public works
projects but the country it simply
couldn't afford to pay for them so
instead of taking responsibility for
their problems and trying to come up
with a solution that made sense they
tried to take the easy way out and just
print more money now look even if you
just have a basic knowledge about how
economics works printing excess money
means there is more currency in
circulation and therefore its overall
value goes down the people in charge
that absolutely no idea what they were
doing and between 1921 1923 they went
through a period of hyperinflation where
the value of just a single US dollar was
equal to several trillion German marks
money was so worthless that kids were
using stacks of money as building blocks
and they cut it up to make kites
whenever someone wanted to buy something
at the store that have to take
a wheelbarrow full of cash with them so
at this point out of Hitler had secured
a job working for the German army as a
confidential informant this was
basically someone who spied on average
citizens to make sure that they weren't
getting into any trouble then in 1919 he
attended a meeting of the German Workers
Party at a bill even though he was sent
as a spy he realized that he actually
rather agreed with everything the
Workers Party was saying they blamed the
Jews for all of the country's problems
and they wanted Germany to go back to
the glorious land it once was this
organization was the precursor to the
National Socialist German Workers Party
or you probably guessed it the Nazis ala
fitler decided to join this party he was
good at public speaking so he was able
to encourage new members to join up - as
the years went on he began to rise in
the ranks of the Nazi leadership and by
November the 8th for 1923 Hitler led
over 2,000 members of the Nazi Party to
the center of Munich and they attempted
to overthrow the German government this
became known as the Beer Hall Putsch
Hitler ins many of the other protesters
they were arrested for treason while he
was in jail Hitler began to write about
his life and his ideas he was supposed
to be in prison for five years but he
only served nine months and he was
released in 1925 wayne was free he
published his autobiography called mine
camp which means my struggle the book
became a best-seller until I became a
millionaire from the sales revenue the
book continued to sell so well that he
made a million dollars every year which
is the equivalent of over 14 million
dollars in today's money the German
people felt that the Vimal Republic was
a total failure because the members of
the government were incompetent many
people could tell that it was only a
matter of time before there was another
revolution thousands of people they
joined either the Communist Party or the
Nazis but the wealthy business owners in
Germany they did not want the Communists
to take over because capitalism would
have been destroyed so the upper-class
began to financially support the Nazi
Party these donations along with
Hitler's new windfall of money helps
make the Nazi Party bigger and better in
a world where there was so much poverty
the Nazis seemed to be prospering and
many people began to believe that it was
truly the best option in the 1920s and
30s investigative journalists began to
dig into and off Hitler's past he was
becoming more of a public figure and he
wanted to know more about him several
magazines published a theory that
Hitler's mysterious biological grand
father was actually Jewish of course
Hitler claims that this was all fake
news propagated by the Jews and that he
was actually a pure-blooded
Aryan German this is despite the fact
that his dark hair and size are far from
the blond-haired blue-eyed ideal that he
loved quite so much
the Nazis governor of Poland Hans Frank
wrote that he uncovered evidence that
Hitler's grandmother Maria Schickel
Gruber received child support payments
from a Jewish man named Leopold
Frankenberger the young man was just 19
when he got 42 year old Maria pregnant
and he did not want to marry her after
their affair in 2010 a DNA test confirms
that Hitler did in fact have Jewish and
even African ancestry
[Music]
it was clear that the German people they
were angry and plenty of people were
trying to come up with peaceful
solutions to retaining a democratic
government in 1924 a man named Charles G
Dawes came up with a plan to borrow
money from American banks and then use
these loans to pay for the coal industry
Germany would sell coal to France and it
would help pay down their debt this was
called Dawes plan and for a while it was
actually working for the first time in
years Germany had hope of recovery in
1925 Charles Dawes was given the Nobel
Peace Prize but in 1929 the United
States stock market crashed
spectacularly and Germany could no
longer rely on those American loans this
marked the beginning of the Great
Depression the Vimal Republic's
Constitution contained a clause called
article 48 which gave the president
power to enforce any law in 1930
president paul von hindenburg began to
use article 48 to create new laws in a
desperate attempt to fix the nation's
economy there was a tremendous amount of
civil unrest and the Nazi Party was
growing larger and more powerful every
single day President Hindenburg could
see that the Nazis posed a threat to the
vemma Republic so he decided that the
only way to maintain democracy in
Germany was for the parties to work
together he appointed a LOF Hitler as
Chancellor of Germany in 1933 just four
weeks later on February 27th 1933 there
iyx tagged parliament building was set
on fire
Hitler claimed that the Communists did
this and too he convinced President
Hindenburg to create laws that bans
freedom of the press and peaceful
protest of course this was just a ploy
to get rid of the Communist Party from
Germany and many people believed that
the Nazis were actually behind the arson
in the summer of 1934 Hitler and his
devout followers Heinrich Himmler and
Herman Goering began the night of the
Long Knives they staged a major coup by
murdering the most powerful members of
the vimar Republic Hitler began to ban
all of the trade unions and made all
other political parties illegal the only
choice German citizen had anymore was to
simply be a Nazi
this was his Third Reich which was an
empire that was apparently going to last
a thousand years
Hitler gave speeches that were full of
hyperbole he claims that everything was
the greatest and made outlandish
promises about the future of Nazi
Germany a lot of people they look back
in history and they wonder how the
German people could have let this
how could they have been so foolish as
to give so much power to one mad man put
yourself in the Germans shoes for just a
second you're a rock bottom
you've got absolutely no hope of feeding
your family or finding any meaning in
your life in your career suddenly a man
with confidence comes along and he
convinces you that you're special you're
a part of this magical master race and
he knows exactly who to blame for all of
your problems and how to make it better
the Germans they fell for it hook line
and sinker
[Music]
Hitler's plan to improve the German
economy was exactly the same way that he
got money all his life instead of
working for it he was simply going to
take it from the people who worked hard
to actually earn it one of his first
decrees was to increase the wages of the
German people by 10.9% which made
everyone happy straight away then he
declared that he would decrease trade
with foreign nations and put all of the
country's money towards military
spending because they were going to make
Germany great and glorious once again at
this point Germany was just as broke
because it was before in the money it
had to come from somewhere
Hitler believed by conquering other
countries they could steal the wealth of
other nations and use that money to run
the Third Reich
so if you're gonna steal from someone
why not start with the wealthiest people
in Europe Jewish homes were ransacked
and their priceless artwork gold and
properties were taken then he moved on
to the ethnic cleansing of the Sinti and
Roma people simply because they were
vagabonds gypsies that he didn't like
having around Hitler decided to
completely ignore the restrictions
placed on Germany in the Treaty of
Versailles as we mentioned earlier
Germany had lost 13% of its territory
but he believed that this perfect Aryan
race needed space to grow the lot of
space he called this the leobens ROM
which means living space and he wanted
to spread German territories throughout
the world even though he claimed he
wanted to exterminate all of the Jews
had lot decided to pick and choose who
he felt was worthy of living he was
grateful to Jewish doctor named Edward
Bloch who treated his mother's breast
cancer block and his wife they were
escorted safely out of Austria Hitler's
personal chauffeur Emil Morris was also
half Jewish and yet he was still allowed
to join the SS because they had been
friends for years
Hitler continued to find like-minded
friends and signed a treaty in 1936 to
join forces with Italy under the rule of
Benito Mussolini meanwhile Japan was
invading China and they had similar
aspirations to conquer territory for
their own empire so they also joined the
Axis powers these three nations began
their plan for a new world order the
concentration camps created a source of
free slave labor for the Nazis which
dramatically cut down on costs the Third
Reich continued to become more powerful
as the years went by millions of people
were dying all because one man decided
to selfishly take everything he could
possibly
he wants and he convinced others to do
the same
after becoming wealthy from the sales of
mine camp in 1925 Hitler had his older
half-sister Angela Roble move into his
home with her children and she became
his housekeeper he was obsessed with his
17-year old niece could gaily revolve
her friends would say that they always
thought they had an oddly close
relationship for an uncle and niece and
many historians have gone so far as to
say that Gilley was the love of his life
when Gary was 19 she began having a
secret affair with Hitler's half Jewish
chauffeur Emil Morris when Hitler found
out he was outraged and Maurice was
fired Hitler sent his sister Angela and
her children's live in a large house
that he purchased in order to get them
away from the city Dini was attending
medical school in Munich so Hitler
suggested she continued living in the
apartment with him alone Hitler forbid
her from having any friends she became a
prisoner in the apartments and he would
not allow her to go anywhere outside of
school unless there was a chaperone even
before he was Chancellor of Germany
Hitler employed a driver and Nazi
bodyguards who were also there to make
sure that he never escaped in 1923 Gary
was now 23 years old and she asked if
she could go on a trip to Vienna to
start taking singing lessons not
surprisingly Hitler refused to let her
leave
gilli finally snapped since they got
into a heated arguments during the fight
give you announced that she had fallen
in love with a young man in classes of
medical school and they were now engaged
to be married she demanded that he let
her leave the apartment so that she
could be with her fiance the next
morning Gillies body was found in a
bedroom with a gunshot wound to the
chest she was holding Hitler's gun in
her hands
it was ruled a suicide but since she had
so much to live for
plenty of people theorized that Hitler's
jealousy got the best of him and that he
murdered his niece many historians
consider this to be a huge turning point
in Hitler's life because it would have
been the first time that he committed
murder outside of the war historians
have been able to find romantic
connections to eight different women in
Hitler's life but he had just one
long-term relationship with a woman
named Eva Braun he met her the same year
that Gilley died in 1929 during a Nazi
Party meeting Eva was just 17 years old
and he was 40 but they were very
attracted to each other since there was
such a huge age gap Hitler claims that
she was his private secretary and kept
their relationship a secret he wanted it
to be a casual relationship so that he
could remain single and enjoy sleeping
with other women whenever he wants it
but Eva Braun was truly in love with
Hitler and it was breaking her heart
that he refused to acknowledge that she
was his girlfriend she attempted suicide
by shooting herself in the chest in 1932
apparently she purposely copied what had
happened to his niece because she knew
it would trigger an emotional response
in him bullet missed her heart and she
got medical attention right away if this
was an elaborate cry for attention it
worked because Hitler ran to her bedside
at the hospital with a bouquet of roses
and told her that he loved her satisfied
that her guilt trip had worked Eva Braun
continued to act like the crazy lovesick
teenager that she truly was she propped
up pictures of Hitler during meals
whenever she ate alone so that she could
pretend that he was there too Eva even
got jealous of the attention that pitler
gave to his dog blondi
she would reportedly kick the dog
whenever it got close to her but Hitler
could never see Eva as anything more
than one of his many mistresses she
never got the nerve and attention that
she wanted from him in 1935 she
attempted suicide again this time by
overdosing on sleeping pills after she
recovered she demanded that if Hitler
didn't want to reveal his secret affairs
they needed to live together in his
bunker in order to stay as long as they
slept in separate bedrooms
[Music]
[Applause]
after years of death and destruction
World War II was finally over and the
Allies won the war on April the 30th
1945 Soviet soldiers were closing in on
Adolf Hitler's bunker he finally agreed
to marry Eva Braun but only if she
agreed to a suicide pact with him she
happily agreed and she wore a black
dress to their wedding Joseph Goebbels
he was the best man he officiated their
intimate ceremony in his last will and
testament
Hitler requested that his body should be
burned after his death when the Russian
stormed the bunker they discovered that
his skull and other bones fragments that
survived the flames for years the USSR
did not allow anyone else access to
Hitler's remains since those bodies in
the bunker could have belonged to anyone
many people felt that they did not have
any real proof that Hitler actually died
this marked conspiracy theories that he
may be still alive some people believed
that he had escapes in a submarine to
start a new life in Argentina in a
German colony called La Cumbre cita The
History Channel devoted an episode of
the series mystery quest called Hitler's
escape to explaining exactly how this
could have been possible for him to pull
off of course they're all so far crazy a
conspiracy theories out there like the
one that claimed that Nazis started a
space colony on the Dark Side of the
Moon nope the idea was so ridiculous it
was turned into a comedy movie called
iron sky but in 2018 scientists finally
confirms the teeth extracted from the
skull in Russia bar in fact out of
Hitler's because it matched his dental
records once and for all people can have
closure and know that he truly did die
in that bunker in 1945 the Nazi Party it
became illegal in Germany and it was
forbidden to even read his autobiography
mine camp until very recently
unfortunately Nazism I stock on away
completely
it was never outlawed in the United
States and this brought on a revival of
the neo-nazi movement as long as we
continue to imagine Hitler as a monster
that only comes along once in a lifetime
will fail to be prepared for an another
evil dictator comes along when powerful
z' into the wrong hands
history can easily be doomed to repeat
itself so I hope you found that video
interesting if you did please do give us
a thumbs up below and don't forget to
subscribe we've got brand new videos
just like this several times a week if
you're looking for something else for me
I've got a daily channel called top 10s
if you click below you'll find a link to
that or just search YouTube for top tens
with a Z and you will find it and as
always
thank you for watching
[Music]
you